yeah welcome to this video playing a sip
team the national master and let's see
how what happens got a cheater and type
i usually don't allow this this line
because I I fail to fail to remember to
correct a great way to play it this
takes e4 really a 36 I this looks
strange really wow night 5 Wow
before this is the problem of this night
wow what the heck is he doing here yeah
this is like playing the worst possible
opening and still try to survive came
threatening work takes a five and
ninety-seven Bishop b5 this is really
unspeakably bad
yeah this is probably probably losing if
you if you play a play well now with
white I don't really see a boost
yeah okay Bishop before the question is
if i go i go 97 first 97 quickie 7 look
a 5 Bishop b4 disturb the stub shall be
five you can play Bishop before maybe
now
what what what a weird position yeah
this one but I really discarded this
instantly this was this a mistake should
i have calculated this I can play before
though we should be for Queen a4s that's
really simple and done Matt b7
so Bishop b5 to c6 this one idea or take
e6 of course yeah like when you cannot
look bad really so we're up c4 yeah this
is good enough that 95 coming yeah King
yet Bishop b5 is rather rather
embarrassing Jack okay yeah not quite
sure where I think what mate i'm going
to go form that they are probably a
couple queen a fourier easiest ones yeah
i don't know what he did there some
somewhere to move all the hiccup I
really think it is lost here this
position this position is probably lost
i don't think yeah minus minus one with
e62 e6 now but this is probably home i
am yeah before it's also good I am no
way to to to to defend this anymore I
think you only need to play e6 here here
you success is a normal position from
the chicken alright thanks for watching